[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my Captain America marvel
infinity saga re-watch breakdown for
Marvel phase 4 covering all the Easter
eggs references and foreshadowing for
Marvel phase 4 and Avengers endgame that
we missed the first time we watched the
movie as part of this we're doing a big
giveaway for the Infinity Saga box set
of all the movies all you have to do to
enter is be subscriber and leave your
favorite Captain America moment on the
video so careful for spoilers for all
the Marvel movies so far well number
these Easter eggs a little differently
as we go through the movie so starting
at the beginning the movie begins with
Captain America's body being discovered
in the wreckage of red skulls bomber
under the ice in the Arctic you notice
that that was part of Nick Fury's map at
the end of Iron Man 2 you may remember
from my Incredible Hulk breakdown video
that there was actually a deleted scene
from that movie where Hulk goes to this
part of the Arctic where his body was
found in an attempt to kill himself and
when the Hulk comes out to stop him he
pounds the ice and frustration creating
a shockwave that was meant to on earth
Captain America's shield so effectively
the Hulk is responsible for the military
finding Captain America's body in the
first place because they had not been
able to find it up to that point then we
traveled Teutons burg Norway in 1940 to
where Red Skull goes to steal the
tesseract it's the same town where Odin
battled the frost giants in the first
Thor flashback it's the same location
which he would eventually go to die in
Thor Ragnarok and it's the same town
where Thor would later build new Asgard
after Avengers infinity war the reason
why oh Dan did the tesseract here is
mostly because the town itself was
special to him he visited many times
over the centuries there was even a
scene in the Thor movie where Erik
Selvig is reading a book depicting Thor
and Odin bringing the tesseract to earth
we meet Red Skull for the first time as
Johann Schmidt wearing his special human
form make up Captain America's most
infamous villain from the classic comics
later during Avengers infinity war in
Avengers endgame though when they
brought him back as the guardian of the
soul stone he was played by a different
actor Ross Marquand from The Walking
Dead he does a pretty good Hugo Weaving
red skull impression but later when Hugo
Weaving was asked why he didn't come
back to do this for Avengers infinity
war in Avengers endgame
he said that originally Marvel had plans
to do all three Captain
movies with red skull changing
everything we know about Captain America
Winter Soldier in civil war with Baron
Zemo
he said originally with each new movie
his role as Red Skull was supposed to
grow as well as the amount of money that
Marvel would pay him for each of the
movies so when they didn't bring him
back for Winter Soldier or Civil War and
then asked him to come back for an
infinity war for a pittance a really
small amount of money he told them no
I'm not coming back in that original
version of the MCU where the Red Skull
would have fit into Winter Soldier and
civil war would have mostly been is a
shadow figure hanging above everything
manipulating everything from behind the
scenes but in this opening scene they
established the creation of Hydra the
name of their group comes from the
mythical Hydra it's the monster with
many heads when you cut one off to grow
back in its place
a reference to Captain America defeating
Red Skull cutting the head off at the
end of the movie but then by present day
Hydra has multiplied its numbers by a
thousandfold the priest in charge of the
church is played by David Bradley who
you all probably recognize from the
Harry Potter movies or as Walder Frey
from Game of Thrones
I wonder if this priest here loves pie
just as much as he does the tesseract
itself is hidden inside the carving of
the World Tree the button to release it
is actually the eye of the serpent which
is a reference to the Midgard serpent in
Norse mythology the Midgard serpent is
Loki's offspring but in the MCU there's
an actual real Midgard serpent that they
had tried to include in the first Thor
movie it was removed for budgetary
reasons but then they tried to bring it
back during Avengers infinity war in
this Avengers infinity war deleted scene
you can see Thor and rocket fighting the
Midgard serpent during this big battle
of Wakanda at the end of the movie they
wound up deleting that scene for
budgetary reasons as well maybe they'll
bring back the Midgard serpent during
Thor for love and thunder since some of
that movie will have to take place on
earth around new Asgard the story of the
tesseract itself in the MCU is a little
different from Marvel Comics the reason
why they included it in this movie was
all foreshadowing for the first Avengers
movie but also because the tesseract is
a reference to the Cosmic Cube in Marvel
Comics which is a big Captain America
Red Skull story beat in those classic
comics the Red Skull is always after the
Cosmic Cube but in the comics the cube
itself does not contain an infinity
stone Kevin
he said that in the MCU movies they
decided to make the tesseract of space
stone just to keep the overarching story
of Fano sin the Infinity Gauntlet a
little easier to follow for people that
did not read the comics the fact that
Red Skull shatters the fake tesseract is
foreshadowing for this scene of fan of
Smashing the tesseract to reveal the
space stone during Avengers infinity war
he has a line of dialogue about the
Fuhrer digging in the desert for
trinkets which is a big reference to
Indiana Jones in the Raiders of the Lost
Ark and you probably noticed several
other Raiders of the Lost Ark references
in some of the scenes like the ending
scene of the movie where Red Skull
seemingly disintegrates as he sucked
through space by the space stone just
like the ending of Raiders but them
getting sucked up into the sky we get
our first iconic line and use of the
shield in the alleyway after he pisses
off a movie heckler they would repeat
this same line several times throughout
the MCU movies okay I can do this all
day
I could do this all day I can do this
all day yeah I know
you also notice behind him here while
he's fighting this guy the word Panther
appears on a boxing poster foreshadowing
his eventual fight against black panther
during Captain America Civil War he's
saved by Bucky who's getting ready to
ship out himself who tells Steve that
they're going get it to the Future
literally and metaphorically
foreshadowing their entire story in the
MCU they then head to the metaphorical
future at the stark Expo which we would
later see during Ironman to the original
one is from Howard Stark who's showing
off early prototypes for the Iron Man
repulsor technology using a precursor
for what would eventually become the
Lola car that Coulson would later
retrofit and use himself we see the
original Human Torch from Marvel Comics
it's a cool Easter Egg for a bunch of
different things though it's an Easter
Egg for not only the original Human
Torch but also the original vision in
the comics and it's a clever reference
to Chris Evans previous role as the
Human Torch in the fantastic four movies
in the eventual debut of the new version
of the Fantastic Four in the MCU after
Marvel phase four the original Human
Torch was also part of the invaders team
with Captain America and get it Namor
another Marvel mutant character that
they've teased will debut in an upcoming
movie most people believe that that will
be black panther 2 because of the way
this scene goes down in avengers endgame
the writers also revealed that this was
intentionally meant to be a name or
easter egg so you can see early on the
Kevin Feige always envisioned crossing
all of Marvel's comic book characters
over like the x-men and Fantastic Four
with the Avengers there's also some
deleted scenes the Kevin Feige had
wanted to include Wolverine and magneto
in some of these World War 2 moments
that we'll talk about in a second - so
there was a lot of x-men stuff that they
had planned to include in these original
phase 1 movies cap and Bucky have their
don't do anything stupid conversations
setting up a beat that they would later
repeat during Avengers end game in their
final goodbyes Steve Rogers meets dr.
Erskine for the first time who says he's
from Queens cap says he's from Brooklyn
a line that they would later bring back
for spider-man in Captain America Civil
War and then we meet Zola for the first
time who's working on tesseract weapons
with Red Skull but his face is Project
on a screen foreshadowing his future in
the Winter Soldier and it's another
moment that they brought back in
Avengers end game when they focus on the
old computer screen in the 70s in that
basement when Howard Stark is yelling
for Zola looking for him it's also meant
to be a reference to comic-book Arnim
Zola who winds up creating an artificial
body for himself later in this Captain
America movie you see diagrams of that
robot body
we meet Peggy Carter for the first time
Captain America throws himself on that
fake grenade believing it's real
foreshadowing pretty much every heroic
decision that he makes later in MCU
movies really good example is the Russos
revealed that had Iron Man not jumped at
the chance to sacrifice himself in
Avengers end game snapping his nano
gauntlet Captain America would have been
the one to throw himself metaphorically
on that grenade first guy tells Captain
America about his history with Red Skull
and the Super Soldier Serum later the US
military would adapt this program into
the weapons Plus program something
general Ross talked about during the
Incredible Hulk movie in present day
with each successive iteration of the
weapons Plus program they attempt to
create super soldiers using slightly
different methods in different versions
of the serum the upcoming Marvel phase
for Falcon and Winter Soldier series on
Disney Plus is gonna continue this
weapons Plus storyline when they learned
that Thunderbolt Ross and someone else
has resurrected the program using it to
create the new dark version of Captain
America with us agent from the comics
he's a version of Captain America that
Thunderbolt Ross can control like a
finger puppet who uses guns just way
more hardcore than Steve Rogers Captain
America this is also a big Wolverine
Easter Egg for Marvel phase 4 and Marvel
phase 5 as Captain America is
designation weapons 1 in the weapons
Plus program Wolverine is designation
weapon 10 that's what the X stands for
Roman numeral 10 the Hulk himself is
also kind of part of the weapons Plus
program because it was revealed during
Incredible Hulk that Thunderbolt Ross
had deceived him into working on gamma
research as part of this telling him it
was for something else but secretly the
hook was working on trying to replicate
the Super Soldier Serum with Thunderbolt
Ross right after he takes the serum they
take a bunch of his blood samples which
later Winter Soldier would be dispatched
to steal from Howard
killing him allowing Hydra to
reverse-engineer the Super Soldier Serum
and give it to several winter soldiers
which we would later see during Captain
America Civil War they also set up the
last dance quote-unquote reference
between Steven Peggy that they'd bring
back at the end of the movie and again
during Avengers endgame when Captain
America would go back in time to
quote-unquote
stay with her for that last dance and as
part of all this Captain America Super
Soldier program you've probably seen the
trailer for Marvel's what-if series
episode one of that is literally going
to be what if Peggy Carter had gotten
the Super Soldier Serum and what if
Captain America had become Iron Man
where a version of skinny Steve Rogers
gets this tank like world war ii version
of the Iron Man armor and when Peggy
gets the Super Soldier Serum she becomes
Captain Britain not Captain America
because she's British not American we
see Captain America chase after that
Hydra agent he uses another improvised
shield just like Spider Man would do
using another card or it has another
star on it then when Red Skull is
testing his new tesseract weapons on the
other soldiers you notice a big Iron Man
Easter egg it sounds very similar to the
way Iron Man's repulsor weapons sound
that's because Howard Stark used the
tesseract to try and create a source of
limitless energy just like the Red Skull
did eventually using it to create the
original arc reactors which Iron Man
would later perfect and used to create
that new element so effectively this
whole time Iron Man's been using
infinity stone technology to power
himself explaining why he can be so
powerful in the MCU later we would also
see Howard Stark experimenting with his
infinity stone energy source it's
foreshadowing for Iron Man creating that
nano Infinity Gauntlet in Avengers
endgame
oh they begin that funny Captain America
PR tour montage he's wearing the first
Captain America costume in that first
shield it's a reference to the original
Captain America comics but the PR tour
itself is a reference to what they did
with Captain America in the real world
during World War two the US military
actually used the Captain America comics
as real-life world war two propaganda to
get the u.s. fired up to buy war bonds
just like they do during the movie and
pump up the US troops during real-life
world war two they even referenced the
cover of the very first Captain America
comic book where he punches Hitler later
you see little kids actually reading
that comic book in the movie later when
Captain America is sketching himself as
a monkey is a reference to Captain
America in the comics being a sketch
artist before he became Captain America
there was an Avengers deleted scene
where he's also sketching the Avengers
tower outside in a cafe later during
Captain America Civil War you saw that
Ironman actually has that original
sketch on his desk so I'm sure he has a
bunch of Captain America original
artwork and storage somewhere it's
probably worth a ton of money now cap
goes AWOL to rescue the missing troops
which include the Howling Commandos from
the comics kenneth joy here is also the
grandfather of spider-man's high school
principal you can see his picture in his
office here Kevin Feige also reveals
some deleted scenes that they were gonna
have during this sequence too he said
that he had wanted to include a version
of Wolverine in a cameo in a young
version of magneto because they were
both part of World War two in the comics
but it would have been Hugh Jackman
playing James Howlett as Wolverine long
before he became Weapon X there was also
a cartoon that showed Wolverines time
with the Howling Commandos obviously the
reason why Hugh Jackman in a young
magneto weren't in the first Captain
America movie was because Kevin Feige
wasn't able to get a deal with Fox to
use the characters at the time but it
would have been one of the best badass
cameos ever then when they go back to
the US base we see his vibranium shield
for the first time Howard's are teasing
that it's the only amount that they've
been able to find on planet earth
because at this point in history Wakanda
was still so secretive no one had
learned about the existence of the
larger vibranium mines yet during the
next Captain America montage of him on
his missions they show his compass with
Peggy Carter's picture which they would
bring back several times in future MCU
movies and again during avengers endgame
when he used it to distract himself when
they go to attack the train bucky
references the cyclone roller coaster at
Coney Island later they brought that
back in spider-man homecoming during
that final fight scene Bucky winds up
using the shield a reference to Bucky
Captain America in the comics a moment
that they bring back during Winter
Soldier there have also been many people
to wield the shield in the comics the
most recent - in the MCU now our Falcon
and US agent during the upcoming Falcon
in Winter Soldier series Captain America
pursues Red Skull to his bomber and
fights him until the tesseract teleports
him to vermeer we later find where he
sought the soul stone only to die and be
forced to become the guardian of the
stone guiding others on their quest to
try and find it so they have teased that
a future version of Red Skull could come
back in a future MCU movie at some point
set in outer space cap says his final
goodbyes to Peggy as the plane goes down
they played their song which they
brought back during Avengers endgame
enduring several other MCU movies Howard
Stark retrieves the tesseract then will
eventually use it to create project
Pegasus which they paid off in the
Captain Marvel movie and in this final
scene he wakes up in present day before
the post-credits scene for the Avengers
movie with in training when Nick Fury
comes to recruit him for the Avengers
initiative because this was meant to be
the last movie right before that first
Avengers film so as you could see there
was a ton of Marvel phase 4 stuff that
they set up in this first Captain
America movie so many years ago so much
Wolverine so much x-men and Fantastic
Four moments everyone let me know if you
spotted any big ones in the movie that I
didn't mention in this video what will
happen is is my next big infinity saga
re-watch video will obviously be for the
first Avengers movie while you wait for
that click here to learn about Marvel's
brand-new Ghost Rider project and click
here for all my Infinity Saga Marvel
phase 4 re watch videos thank you so
much for watching everyone stays safe
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]